get a set of rooks off the board that's
when the moment's right start advancing
those white pawns on the right side
that's where your strengths lie he does
allow the trade of rooks but
with his bishop first oh look at magnus
he hates this
i have a feeling magnus just
mouth-slipped on the last move as well
as okay he hates it anyway he hates his
position he's
just losing frankly pawn down from
nothing okay
but as mouse slips goes it's not the
worst one i mean
so i think he meant to move the black
king back towards the center back to a
light square but he put it in the corner
where it's definitely no good he's being
trapped there uh i could imagine it
being trapped there later in the game at
least
so magnus he needs yeah
he needs a lot of help now from rajabov
to get a bit of hope
wow i can't uh believe the drama they
actually did bring us in this match
a win for magnus in game three and it's
looking very difficult for him
in game four yeah raj above just pushing
a pawn on the left side
just clamping